[Aplausos]
[Música]
creciendo mi vida en perú pues fue
divertida
soy la menor de tres hermanas y wendy me
lleva nueve años
pamela me lleva siete años y yo tengo 23
y pronto voy a cumplir 24 suena
razonamiento matemático cuántos años
tienen mis hermanas para ver su men psuv
en estos casos mi papá se llama manuel
josé manuel barreiro armenio estuve en
la marina fue botones por muchos años en
un hotel cinco estrellas
y después fue repartidor en una tienda
pituca en san isidro
y hoy en día pues mi papá tak sea aunque
no le gusta que lo llamen taxista mi
papá le gusta que le llamen conductor
privado ya después cuando quieran les
mandó su tarjeta para que lo contacten
y mi mamá se llama elizabeth francis
anchante y es cesante de la sanidad de
la policía
soy nieta de meche de tina de abraham y
de tíos abuelos los cuales no conocí
pero que los nombro porque yo los
recuerdo
y yo soy ellos y si no fuera por ellos
yo no estaría hoy en día diciendo este
speech quiero empezar siempre nombrando
las personas que me permitieron mi
existencia
desde pequeña mis padres me invitaron a
ser creativa
yo creo que nací siendo creativa mi
color favorito es el morado y según
google el morado es el color de la
creatividad y de lujo aunque el lujo ya
no me importa tanto
siempre he sido creativa a pesar de
vivir en una quinta y digo a pesar
porque cada vez que me levanto en las
mañanas lo primero que veo por la
ventana son fierros abarrotes y una
pared de ladrillos es la casa de mi tío
que vive al frente
siempre fue mi primera vista los
barrotes son porque mi hermana familia
cuando era pequeña una vez quiso volar y
casi todo se tira por la ventana mi
hermana no tenía nociones de lo que es
la gravedad y tenía complejo de súper
mujer aún sigo pensando que mi hermana
es una súper mujer pero para volar pues
puede tomar un avión no éramos pajaritos
que soñaban cantaban jugaban en una
quinta en una jaulita en breña
para los que no saben que es una quinta
es muy particular para las familias afro
peruanas esta es la evolución de un
callejón de un solo caño hoy en día son
casas divididas por un pasillo con
sistema de agua y de luz propio
mi quinta puede ser particular como iría
echado
mi quinta pues vivieron mis tíos y mis
abuelos de parte madre
mis vecinos de diferentes partes del
perú las quintas hablan saben las
quintas cuentan historias en la mía se
habla en historias afroperuanas se habla
en historias japonesas chinas indígenas
e indígenas amazónicas mi quinta es como
el perú y nos hemos echado y nos hemos
peleado con nuestros vecinos tal y como
el perú lo hace nos hemos echado con los
de adentro y con los de afuera
en mi jaula y está en breña ya grandes
teníamos las llaves para salir mis papás
nos enseñaron y nos dieron las llaves
para poder entrar y salir cuando
quisiéramos
podríamos ir y conocer el mundo o al
menos nuestra cuadra o ir a la esquina a
la tienda del señor roger a comprar una
cajetilla de cigarros y un caramelo
heights yo sé que los preconceptos hacia
los niños de comprar alcohol y cigarros
pero yo he estado ahí a mí también me ha
mandado a comprar chela en una fiesta
cuando me tocó salir por la puerta de mi
casita es la jaula me di cuenta que
habían muchas cosas que me confundían de
este país
al parecer la confusión se originaba por
como lo hacía yo
mi color de piel era una confusión para
otros y comenzó a hacer una confusión
para mí
y es que a dónde iba ni hacía ni me
sentía un diente extraño
hacían bromas en la calle me hacían
bromas en el nido me hacían bromas en el
colegio hablara o no
siempre me trataban diferente y eso me
confundía
y era un tema al cual cargaba a todos
lados
y como pensaba
pero bueno
para mí la verdad todo esto no tenía
sentido
yo nunca me peleaba con nadie nunca me
echaba porque no tenía sentido para mí
hacerle daño a alguien hacerle algo a
alguien que no me gustaría que me lo
hagan a mí
en verdad para mí nada de esto tenía
sentido
siempre
me sentía algo mal por algo lo cual en
mi casa me habían enseñado a sentirme
orgullosa me decían que tenía que
sentirme bien porque mis papás a mí me
hablaban acerca de la cultura
afroperuana de la música del ritmo de la
cultura de la importancia de la cultura
de los poemas de la literatura de los
pregones me contaban de mi historia me
contaban de la historia de todos
yo he sido visible invisible en mi
propio país
pero yo sé que en los tonos de todo el
mundo cuando ponen la hora loca se ponen
a bailar festejo y samba cueca ya y ahí
estamos estamos ahí los afroperuanos y
cuando se exponen a comer en el día
criollo pues comen la comida que los
afroperuanos creamos sin embargo en la
historia y en el colegio nos cuentan
solamente pequeñas partes cuando hemos
sido parte de la construcción del perú
que conocemos hoy en día a veces creo
que el perú no sería el perú si en el
aporte de los afroperuanos
constantemente me han preguntado de
dónde soy no y mi respuesta nunca ha
sido suficiente de dónde eres hay señito
yo soy de breña no no de dónde eres el
semáforo que vea ya a la derecha señor
no no de dónde eres como si fuera un
secreto
allá yo soy de acá
usted de dónde es
y cuando la pregunta era ya más
específica amiga dime de qué país eres
yo decía soy de peru
ustedes desde el mercurio
pero era lo que me tocaba vivir es lo
que me toca vivir
y eso no termina acá porque creciendo
hubo mucha más confusión
después tuve que enterarme de lo que
implica ser leída como mujer creciendo
en lima que según el plan internacional
es una de la ciudad más insegura para
una joven que sale suela de su casa o
usa el transporte público tanto en la
noche como en el día
y sí que el machismo me ha afectado
me ha golpeado duro
he estado como esa canción de shakira
que el amor sin cuidados y sin
comunicación te hace ciega sorda y muda
bruta torpe y testaruda amiga yo he
estado ahí
mi existencia creciendo en este mundo
estuvo llena de por qué es pero eso no
me detuvo
creo que inconscientemente
siempre he buscado una respuesta
yo me decidió en estudiar publicidad y
estudia publicidad porque por muchos
años hice improvisación teatral justo
con germán loero el que acaban de ver
hace un rato él fue mi profesor de impro
y me encantaba contar historias y al
decir así a todo esa era la única regla
el no no existía
en la improvisación podía ser quien se
me dé la gana más allá de mi vehículo
cuerpo físico materia
no estudié actuación por los
preconceptos que se tiene hacia el
teatro y el tema del arte y el tema
monetario
yo pues me fui por otra carrera
y preferí estudiar publicidad
pero encontré en la publicidad
aquella carrera que te vende aquello que
no necesitas o si depende lo quieres
en la publicidad me di cuenta que era
algo parecido a la improvisación
me daban un tema me daban un producto y
yo te creaba toda una historia
con inicio nudo un desenlace
que se iba hablar por distintos medios
de comunicación era fantástico mis
primeros años en mi carrera de
publicidad pues
teníamos clases de creatividad redacción
creativa me invitaban a imaginar ya
crear
hice una página tan buena de una marca
tan conocida que la gente me escribía a
mi página falsa obviamente a comprarme
atún y también a quejarse porque a veces
el atún venía con mosca
mis primeros ciclos en verdad fueron
geniales hasta que me di cuenta que mi
carrera también tenía preconceptos tenía
estereotipos y clasificaban a las
personas quien podía y quien no adquirir
un producto y acceder a tipos de
servicios y ahí fue donde comencé a
despertar comencé a intuir y
principalmente a cuestionar porque mi
color de piel era un tema tan importante
y un problema para los demás y para mí
la respuesta era racismo
comencé a conocer esta palabra y la
problemática y el origen de esta un tema
que tenemos tan interiorizado y que
nadie lo ve
desigualdades que hemos aprendido desde
pequeños donde ponen a unos más altos
que a otros lo positivo de este problema
al parecer era es que yo no tenía aquí
muy lejos para entender la problemática
tenía las respuestas a la pobreza tenía
las respuestas a la riqueza al machismo
a racismo el clasismo a la fobia y a los
tantos sismos y problemáticas sociales
que existen en nuestro país
a este mundo
porque yo lo pude ver en mi familia lo
pude ver en la sociedad en el estado y
lo más importante lo pude ver en mí
también
en mi misma
un día hablando con una amiga llamada
daniela román en el micro pues estuvimos
conversando y ella me decía hoy en día
no hay influencias que hablen acerca de
las problemáticas sociales que ocurren
en nuestro país y yo le decía sí qué
terrible debería de ver a alguien no un
día fuimos a nuestra clase de redacción
creativa y le dijimos a la profesora que
sería interesante que cada uno creó un
blog y una página y comenzar a hablar
acerca de un tema unos iban a hablar
acerca de la vida fitness otros iban a
hacer programas en la calle yo iba a
hablar de racismo
no sé si me iba a escuchar no me
importaba yo iba a hablar de racismo
la profesora pues no estaba tan feliz me
dijo que no iba a funcionar porque en el
perú no hay tanto racismo como antes y
yo dije obviamente mis ya no matan gente
no pero pasa esto pasa esto pero no me
creyeron
me dijeron que no que el racismo está en
mi mente y que yo lo estaba tomando muy
personal
era complejo no entendía ni siquiera me
dejaron terminar mi exposición
mis compañeros de ese día no estaban muy
felices porque aparte hacer blog es algo
difícil y es mucha producción para una
sola persona pero tampoco me apoyaron
ese día de la exposición
igual que mi hermana yo ese día tuve
complejo de súper mujer lo cual no le
recomiendo a nadie y dije a la miércoles
me crean o no yo lo voy a hacer
agarrón todos mis compañeros no paraban
de decirme natalia el racismo en tu
mente lo tomas muy personal por un
segundo pensé acaso estoy loca solo
pasto dos personas que digieran yo he
visto mi amiga a natalia siendo
discriminada en el propio instituto y
otra amiga que no era toda mi amiga pero
dijo si está hablando de tantas personas
yo no creo que esté mintiendo o no
la profesora dijo que había generado
polémica y quería ver eso en las redes
sociales no lo dijo porque pensó de que
el racismo y combatir esto era algo
bueno ella quería haber pleito
probablemente si lo estaba tomando
personal y es que es un tema personal no
probablemente si estoy resentida porque
esto me ha dañado
probablemente si el racismo esté en mi
mente está en la mente de todos porque
el racismo es mental y también el
racismo es sistemático o no no sé salía
arrebatada y molesta me acuerdo a punto
de llorar y llamé a mi papá y le dije no
puedo creer que estas cosas estén
pasando y mi papá que ahora tiene 61
años de negro me dijo así es la vida
pues natalie así son las cosas vas a
tener que enseñarles
tenía que enseñarles
yo quería hablar de esa parte no tan
bonita de ser una persona negra en el
perú quería hablar de ese amigo
invisible que está en la mente de todo
el mundo el primer vídeo de una chica
afro peruana así llamé mi blog fue un
éxito al parecer había más personas
buscando hablar y entender y escuchar de
como el racismo atormentaba sus vidas
hacía vídeos diciendo hola que tal mi
nombre es note la barrera francis y soy
una chica afroperuana obviamente porque
soy afro y soy peruana
y a la gente le gustaba
en verdad tenía muchos likes
una chica pro peruana me ayuda a sanar
me ayuda a hablar de mi dolor de mi
furia de mi molestia de mi ira me ayudó
a soltar muchas cosas
puede permitirme hablar de mis emociones
y poco a poco estas se transformaron en
alegría y empatía
y me comenzaron a llamar activista
y yo comencé a decir que lo era yo no
sabía lo que significaba esa palabra
activistas alguien que está activo en
una campaña a favor de un cambio social
o cuestiones políticas y dije bueno si
eso es activismo yo soy activista lo
asumí
cuando en verdad yo solamente comparto
mi historia
yo solo estaba buscando mi buscándonos
en un país donde el negro solamente es
el 3% de la población y crecí no viendo
muchas personas como yo ni en la
televisión ni en la calle vivo en un
país donde nos han mostrado que los
afrodescendientes
solamente somos el entretenimiento
pero cuando salimos de esas categorías
la vida se hace dura y complicada porque
las opciones y las puertas son limitadas
en este proceso de entendimiento y de
comprensión y de reconexión conmigo
misma comencé a escuchar y observar de
cómo la gente reaccionaba a mi contenido
había positivismo y había negatividad me
llamaban resentida y amargada y otros me
llamaban resiliente y en algún momento
me llamaron la voz del bicentenario
yo no sé yo solo contado mi historia mi
obstáculo que era mi color de piel me
permitió volar a diferentes países me
llevó a lugares que no conocía ni
siquiera su existencia lo siento yo no
me sé todo el globo terráqueo pero una
vez llegué a líbano a un foro de la paz
para contar acerca de la paz a través de
la tecnología y después me obstáculo me
hizo volar a diferentes países en
latinoamérica para ser presentadora de
una serie llamada descolonizar que la
pueden sintonizar ahora en youtube donde
viajamos a brasil a colombia a puerto
rico a perú a diferentes lados a chile y
argentina para conocer a personas que
utilizan su cultura como herramienta en
contra la colonización
en este obstáculo pues
conocí a cantantes bailarines
congresistas y parteras trans marrones
conocí a un biólogo que es drag que
también es profesor de arte y conocí a
mujeres peinadoras que cuentan historias
a través de su cabello y me surgieron
más porque es
acaso en este mundo donde no nos
permiten hablar de nuestros sentimientos
y de nuestra cultura sin decir que somos
frágiles no nos permiten hablar acaso de
esto acaso el sentimiento no es humano
acaso somos robots perú no deberíamos de
sentir entonces comprender nuestra
humanidad no debería de pasar esto
entonces como evolucionamos entonces
es que
porque asumimos porque asumimos que hay
personas superiores a nosotros y porque
lo aceptamos
acaso no nos enseñan que en todos lados
todas las personas tenemos el mismo
valor
así nosotros pensemos distinto
es obviamente que no somos iguales yo me
miro al espejo y soy marrón pero porque
asumimos si no conocemos a la persona
que no tenemos a nuestro costado
pero acaso no nos han enseñado el
respeto y los valores en el colegio
acaso el conocimiento solo surge en las
universidades en los colegios de los
diplomas y en los trabajos grandes donde
ganas mucho dinero
acaso tener más dinero te hace dueño del
mundo yo pensé que el mundo era de las
personas lo cual todos habitamos
bueno todos pensamos diferente y
probablemente tenemos diferentes
opiniones y respuestas sobre estas
preguntas mi confusión fue tan fuerte de
niña de adolescente de adulta que me
llevó a tener un cortocircuito así lo
llamamos donde la información en mi
cerebro simplemente hizo
es gracioso creo yo
porque mi confusión tenía respuesta y
sólo tenía que vivir
comunicarme escuchar y estar presente en
esa escucha y comprender
somos tan diferentes en este mundo con
perspectivas tan distintas y con
pensamientos tan distintos pero los
valores los valores amigos son
universales
pero a veces nos olvidamos cuando
salimos de nuestra jaulita en nuestro
día a día
porque esto en verdad ya no es una
guerra
no es una guerra de negros contra
blancos no es derecha ni izquierda no es
capitalismo socialismo no es fácil o
difícil
no es hacer un preconcepto porque hacer
un preconcepto algo es tan estúpido como
clasificarlo pero somos peruanos sale
una papa nueva con un cromosoma x y la
llaman con un nombre diferente porque
ser humano es perfecto en clasificar
no tenemos que asumir porque asumir es
tonto es escuchar y de nuevo repito
estate presente en esa escucha y deja tu
diego de lado algunos ahora me dirán que
me rendí dirán que soy tibia y dirán que
soy centralista no sé yo solamente
pueden tome historia
hay que sensibilizarnos creo yo porque
mientras más reaccionamos más nos
integramos y sabemos que están
fragmentados ya estamos
antes de terminar
quiero hablar de ese momento que yo
hablaba de las llaves de mi casa
que mis papás me dieron literal si
constantemente yo soy una de las hijas
que pierden las llaves físicamente pero
yo cuando hablo de llaves no hablo de
este material físico de metal sino hablo
de las llaves del conocimiento que mis
papás me dieron creciendo y otras que he
ido aprendiendo en el proceso mientras
que ido adquiriendo claridad
bueno les cuento un poco de mí yo he
sido la hija que expulsaron del colegio
yo fui la hija que mentía yo he sido la
hija que robó ganchitos en tweets yo he
sido la hija que decepcionó yo he sido
la hija que pensó que no era capaz yo
fui la hija que pensó que la vida no
tenía sentido para vivirla fui la hija
que asumió muchas veces que fue
prejuiciosa y clasificó a las personas y
la que pensó que tenía solamente una
herida que contar y que solamente yo
eran mis etiquetas
fui la hija que terminó yendo un
psiquiatra por pensar que podía hacerlo
todo y probablemente si puedo hacerlo
todo pero no todo a la vez
los obstáculos juegan un rol importante
en nuestras vidas y hay que asumirlos
hay que asumirlos con responsabilidad y
sin culpa las problemáticas sociales se
están convirtiendo hoy en día y hay
personas en todo el mundo que están
tratando de restaurarlo sistemáticamente
roto no pierdas la fe
asumamos nuestra responsabilidad
porque somos aquellas personas que están
en la línea del tiempo que probablemente
genere un cambio o no en un futuro acaso
eso importa está bien porque no
necesitas ver los resultados para
comenzar a ser una mejor persona
deja tu individualismo te digo déjalo de
lado
no soy perfecta gracias a dios gracias
al universo al espiritualismo lo como lo
queramos llamar
he perdido mis llaves constantemente
pero al fin comprendí como dijera como
hubiera dicho victoria bastante cruz yo
soy un cuerpo estoy natalia y he venido
a este mundo para aprender a vivir y ser
feliz y ahora quiero terminar esto con
una pregunta y tú tú para qué has venido
y ahora que me estás buscando esa
respuesta
estás dispuesto para vivir una nueva
experiencia
gracias
[Aplausos]